- Today we're trying this vodka infused
with kale, lemon peel, and cucumber.
And apparently it might
prevent Asian glow.
- Maybe.
(upbeat synth music)
- Asian glow is when you get
real red and hot and sad.
- When I started getting it,
I was embarrassed too, because
people would think I'm really drunk
when I wasn't that drunk yet.
After one shot, I would just get red.
- Within like few
minutes, I turn beet red.
- Normally, I turn
maroon, like a love seat.
- Wine color.
When you go to the bathroom and you look
in the mirror and you're like, "whoa"
- My face gets puffy.
- My whole body swells,
pounding headaches,
blurred vision, whole
list of side-effects.
That happen when I'm drunk.
- I'll start feeling like,
really heavy in my shoulders,
I've never gotten a hangover the next day.
- Yeah.
- I get it the night of.
- It's gotten worse as I've gotten older.
- My experience with alcohol is
my experience with Asian glow.
You can't separate the two.
- I looked it up and they
said you can take Pepcid
to prevent it, so I started doing that.
90 percent of the time, it works.
- I actually have a bottle
of Pepcid in my car,
at my desk, at home, in the nightstand.
With Pepcid, you get slightly pink,
but not like crazy red.
- My regimen, two Xantax
and then I take a Claritin,
and then I'll get like a burger.
I'm armed with eyedrops.
But if I do it properly, then
I like will have nothing.
- I used to do that and then I just
got tired of bringing pills.
It's kind of weird.
I just pop these pills before
I really start to party.
- It would be amazing if I didn't
have to take Pepcid every time before.
- I was at an event, asked
the person behind the bar
if I could get the tiniest bit of alcohol,
she said I might not
get an allergic reaction
with this vodka and I was skeptical of it.
The next day at work,
messaged all the Asian people,
and was like, I found
this drink that might
prevent Asian glow and
we're like "what the heck?"
And we were all excited to try it to see
if this can actually work, 'cause it would
be a game-changer for Asian people.
We do wanna say that the vodka
wasn't made for Asian glow.
Maggie just happened to find it.
We're kinda just testing it on our own.
(upbeat techno music)
- It smells fruity to me.
- It smells lemon-y.
- Healthy juice.
- Veggies.
- It does smell like kale.
- Really?
What does kale smell like?
- Kale smells like kale.
- Let's do this.
- It's a really nice, lemon-y aftertaste.
- The kale aftertaste, I don't mind.
- I know like in Willy Wonka
- Yeah?
- There was like the gum
all the meals and then
you become a blueberry?
It's kind of like that, but for a salad.
- Whoo.
(loud audible burp)
- Good god, Nikki.
- I found out that the alcohol
doesn't have histamines in it.
- It's super-distilled.
Usually Pepcid is a histamine blocker,
we think that might be why
we might not get Asian glow from it.
- Water mixed with lemon and a shot.
- Okay.
- I don't taste the alcohol at all.
- I don't taste it either.
- Really refreshing, super-clean.
- This just tastes like lemon juice.
- To me, it tastes like one of those
shots you get at like a juice bar.
Like a health shot.
- It tastes great so I
don't need the extra sugar.
- It's great if you're trying
to lose a couple pounds.
- My face is very hot.
- I'm actually feeling the
heat right now, though.
- I'm sorry, I'm starting
to really feel this alcohol.
- Oh no, how many minutes has it been?
(sharp string music)
- Are the cameras rolling?
- [Off-Screen] Yeah.
- Oh.
(laughs)
- This vodka, I've noticed that
one shot is actually pretty strong.
- Yeah.
Is it weird that my burps taste good?
- In the past year, I've maybe had
a sip of other people's drinks.
Never my own.
It's expensive.
- Normally, I would get red.
It starts here and then it just like
slowly transitions down
to my neck and shoulders.
- It's like Mystique in X-Men.
- Sober Maggie to Drunk Maggie.
- Back in the day, when water was dirty,
Europeans drank alcohol
and Asians drank tea.
- So they built up a tolerance to it
and we didn't, so we
can drink loads of tea.
I drink no alcohol.
- We like lack an emzyme.
- An enzyme.
- (unison) We lack an enzyme.
- So we can't process dairy and
we can't process alcohol.
- It's great.
- I'm part white!
- Where's my enzyme?
- I'm a little bit white.
- My mom's half-white.
- I'm a little white.
I'm 1/8 white.
- I'm more white than you.
- I think right now,
instead of Asian glow,
it just looks like you ran a lap.
- I look like I'm very athletic.
- I feel great!
- I do feel a little bit buzzy
and one shot of vodka
would not make me buzzy.
You're just nodding
your head like you're...
- 'Cause I'm wasted right now.
(laughing)
- Do you feel my face getting red and hot?
- I feel your face.
I feel tingly.
Aww, damnit, I have so much to do.
- Who told you this was a thing?
They're a liar.
I feel like I (clears throat)
live a very full life
without this feeling.
(techno/EDM music)
- Alright so right now, we're about
to check selfie cams to look at how
red we are compared to normal.
- Oh wow!
- [VO 1] You look a little shiny.
- [VO 2] I'm a little shiny.
- [VO 1] A little rosy right here.
Now I'm getting red.
I'm kinda disappointed, I really
thought this was not gonna make me red.
- Usually, I'm a lot redder.
- This look good, like I look like I'm
wearing blush, like on purpose.
- This did not work for me.
I feel like I do every time I drink.
- I'm only like slightly pink,
usually I get so red.
As pink as I would if I took Pepcid
and I need to drink this more often.
Yeah, no this is nothing.
This is like me just doing a few sit-ups.
This is probably how I normally turn,
when I take a Pepcid, so without taking
Pepcid and added chemicals, just having
the alcohol, this is great.
- I'm a little, a little pink here.
It's actually super-mild right now.
- Yeah, I don't know, like I can't
really tell if I'm...
- [Off-Screen] I think it worked on you.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- I totally recommend the cure vodka.
I feel amazing, I love the taste.
I would drink this again.
This is my new go-to drink.
- I just wanna take a nap.
I just wanna lie down.
- I feel great, I wanna
hug everybody in this room.
I feel super.
- I don't feel like I'm dying.
I don't feel like I need to sleep.
- I don't think that preventing
Asian glow worked on me.
- I don't think that I would
go out of my way to like buy a bottle of
magic Asian vodka.
- I've just been sipping on it,
like over in the corner,
so I guess I would drink it again.
- I feel like I do every time I drink.
And I think I look this way too.
- I, for sure, would try this again.
Usually, I'll take one shot and
feel like I'm gonna throw up everywhere.
But I feel really good.
I'll put it in a flask,
take it with me wherever.
- So this is the end of our test.
It's not super-scientific.
Out of eight people that we tested today,
eight out of five worked.
- Jayne.
- Five out of eight worked!
You kinda have to try it for yourself.
We don't know, we have no idea.
We're not scientists.
We don't know why or how,
we are just regular people.
- I think it's the histamines, right?
- Could be the histamines.
- I'm totally on board for this.
- I just wanna dance.
- Do you wanna dance?
- I wanna dance.
- We should dance.
There's a sound system,
it's the end of the day,
it's Friday.
- Yes, I personally would try it again.
And maybe for the people that it
doesn't work on, hopefully there's
something else that will work for you.
- Exactly.